you said when you started out in stand
up and to this day you're one of those
guys that sweats in his armpits a lot
yes and you went and got Botox in your
armpits yes and that what does that do
does that just freeze up the sweat
glands okay so I get anxiety right yeah
and you're right because I watch a lot
of specials and these guys are soaking
wet drenched drenched I'm not a good
look I don't like the look no so prior
to going on stage prior to doing
anything right prior to getting on here
right I would sweat right so the the the
even though you use deodorant I don't
use deodorant I don't stink by the way
no but wouldn't you when you were
sweating if you use deodorant why don't
you use deodorant are you afraid it
gives cancer that yeah and I uh it
didn't help I tried it you sweat so much
right through it oh my God an
antiperspirant yeah I'll try to do every
one is that a genetic thing do your
parents sweat a lot I mean I mean that's
unusual to sweat through deodorant no I
I it's not the hereditary as far as I
know it's an embarrassing thing it's
embarrassing yeah it was so bad it was
it was coming down to my hip
I'm like what's going on like your
underwear was wet yeah I thought it was
passing away
did you go to the doctor I went to the
dermatologist I go doc I'm leaking
something's wrong
what could be leaking yeah
so he goes you got hyperhidrosis ah so
some people sweat they get clammy hands
he goes you're pissing hard I'll give
you some Botox and I said all right
shoot me up let's see where this goes
yeah so he shot me up with like a vial
and a half on each armpit well you're
nervous because it's supposed to be like
rat poison uh Botox yeah I I to be
honest with you I didn't do a lot of
research on the side effects I just said
you know if it's going to stop uh me
sweating you're a performer yeah yeah
I'll take the side effects right so it
did help I don't sweat out of my armpits
anymore but now my ass is drenched so I
don't know what do you mean are you
being serious it's rerouted itself so
now your ass sweats you mean your cheeks
it's damp yeah are you damp now I'm not
deaf no no good you realize you're
relaxed but when you're on stage when
I'm watching like that Netflix special
or I go to see at Madison Square Garden
which you'll be appearing uh at soon you
literally get asked what yeah I'm damp
like a lot of my a lot of my jeans in
this area here yeah because uh like if
they're black they become like a whitish
after right by your crotch
yeah
could they Botox your ass and see where
the next I mean how many things you're
gonna go for you know by the time you're
done with this you're going to be
sweating out your kneecaps what if you
put a tampon between your cheeks would
that soaking some of the moisture I
don't know I tell you the human body is
unbelievable it is it's unbelievably
embarrassing it's just so weird
foreign